good morning hi yes I'm Richard Tibbets
we're gonna talk about Bayes DB brief
bio I spent most of the last 15 years
working on streaming SQL real-time
streaming systems which meant I spent a
lot of time looking at programming
languages and databases and thinking
about visual programming environments as
well as query languages and that's how I
ended up reconnecting with the
probabilistic computing group and in
fact working on Bayes DB and the
Bayesian query language probabilistic
computing group is an academic research
group and so you know just to
acknowledge there's a this is not work
that I joined the project less than two
months ago this is work that is largely
accomplished you know not by me I didn't
write most of the code I am just the
person who wanted to come here and talk
about it because I'm very excited about
what we're doing
so query the probable implications of
data what does that actually mean or why
would we do that actually so why would
we want to query the probable
implications of data because it's like
hard to think about probability to think
about statistics to understand what your
data means everybody's getting excited
about big data but people are making a
lot of mistakes people doing science
people doing sociological research
people doing business healthcare they're
doing a lot of mistakes and they have a
lot of trouble feeling confident in the
results of their analysis when someone
tells them something because the
computer said so they have an inherent
willingness to believe that the
computers probably right but when they
try to drill down any deeper than that
you know it's it's tough and so more
often than not people are willing to
discount data analysis in favor of their
gut check unless they really understand
it and so in order to get there we need
to get to a place where more and more
people can understand data analysis and
can understand what it means to infer
something from empirical data and
academic computer science broadly
considered well let's not throw rocks at
academic computer science let's just
throw rocks at databases because I'm
from the database community and systems
programming
databases have done a lot over the last
thirty years they have mostly made
things faster and prettier and consume a
lot more data
and better index and faster and faster
but in terms of the ability to ask
really new different questions of your
data
you know since business intelligence and
hypercube type stuff and not a lot of
adopted innovation coming out of the
database community for new kinds of
questions so everybody understands
databases so if I have a database that
contains a population so it's a contains
some samples and people so this is would
be healthcare data maybe it has
combination of columns it could be
actually quite wide but doesn't fit on
the slide then has some columns related
to demographic information healthcare
costs clinical indicators you know just
basic stuff you would get at any doctor
visit but then also more substantial
indicators that someone's been diagnosed
with some issue or something along those
lines and so it's it's a wide data set
it's a large data set potentially it
tends to be a bit sparse in some places
so a lot of times we don't know if you
have heart disease or not most people in
the room don't know if they have heart
disease or not and that's interesting so
people know what select does select is
kind of the go-to keyword in SQL so when
we select from data we pick out a subset
of the data so I start with a bunch of
data and I get less data that's good so
what are we talking about with querying
the implications of data well we can
introduce a new keyword we can have a
keyword called infer in fact we sorry I
should say we have introduced a new
keyword and by the way I'll get to it at
the end but this is actually software
that runs and you can run it there are
some caveats it's not ready to go
diagnose people with chronic heart
disease but it is is runnable it is
something we would like people to be
doing some work with and so what is
infer do so infer says I want these
records with this predicate but I
actually want you to generate fill in
missing data fill in stuff that I don't
know as long as you think you know it
with at least confidence 0.7 and a key
thing we haven't done here is to say
what the data model is or how the data
should be modeled or which model is no I
didn't say random forests I didn't say
scikit-learn
there's no R code there's like nothing
what we're focusing on with bql and with
this querying the implications of data
is to say what are
primitives that make sense what are the
things that you can ask of a modelled
population a population that has a set
of models remodel associated with it and
let's make sure that we get the
utterances right and then see what we
can do with that
so infer says find me patients where
their age is greater than 30 and what
you can see is that I was able to infer
for example the total cost for patient
133 I was able to infer the age for
patient 132 but I wasn't actually able
to infer whether patient 131 has heart
disease so I can leave that blank I can
do more things so I can actually look at
I can inspect the model I can say what
do we how do we think about this data
what's this sort of what's important so
in particular I can say what columns in
my population predict height so what's
the predictive probability and this
doesn't say that there's some linear
correlation it doesn't say that bigger
age is bigger height and bigger gender
is bigger height that doesn't make sense
it just says that these are the columns
that are most useful if you wanted to
predict someone's height so that's kind
of that this is in somewhat intuitively
obvious for height you know age weight
gender although the fact that chronic
kidney disease has an impact on height
might be an interesting insight and if
you run this on some more complicated
data and you start to ask you know which
of these columns that represent
biomarkers or med of logical indicators
are most correlated with having a
particular form of diabetes or
malnutrition then the predictive
probability becomes very interesting in
fact you can also turn this around and
say if I was doing a survey and for some
reason I needed to predict people's
height what questions should I ask so
you can also tell you what do you need
to know in the future to predict
something so there's this notion of
estimating dependent probability and
then finally there's a simulation so
what if scenarios to use a business
buzzword so we can not only infer
missing data and talk about the
predictive power but we can also
simulate new data and so in this case
I'm just making up new patients all
under age 10 and trying to get an
understanding of given my model what
would they look like what would patients
that that you know how often do they
have
kidney disease that sort of thing this
is helpful for filling in blind spots
and we'll get in to that a little bit
later but it's you know I may not have
many observations of patients under age
10 with chronic kidney disease but if I
have a rich enough model then I can
invent new observations and use those to
think about problems
so what's Bayes DB Bayes DB is the the
Bayesian query language the BD v v ql
which is this SQL like language we've
been looking at and so that gets you
model independent queries and that's
actually one of the most powerful things
that we have going here is the idea that
you can think about the question without
knowing about how the data is modeled or
what the architecture is this is similar
to how SQL databases allowed us to
separate asking the question from
thinking about the physical layout of
data on disk
you know once upon a time if you wanted
to summarize some data you had to know
you would use Perl or some cobalt scary
thing and you had to know how the
records were laid out how you wanted to
iterate over the records what tape drive
they were on all that jazz and databases
said no if you get your data into this
format you can then ask it pretty much
any question you want and we'll find a
way to answer that question hopefully
fast enough
what we're doing with with bql is to say
if you can get your question into this
format if you can get your model data
into our system then you can ask any
question you want and we'll give you an
answer with a certain level of
confidence if you don't have any models
for it we'll get into that later so we
need to be able to answer people's
questions and so in addition to these
model independent queries we also have
you know that's front of the house we
have back of the house which is the meta
modeling language so that's how do we
represent models how do we think about
modeling data in this system it starts
with an automatic model builder so we
actually have the ability to you know
model data in model basically arbitrary
tabular data to the best of our
abilities and then layered on top of
that is the ability to plug in foreign
models algorithmic and statistical
models then we call that machine
assisted modeling so I'll start with
Bayes DB let's talk about just the bql
part so we're going to work with a data
set
from the you've concerned SATA a concern
saddle scientists which is this
population of satellite data so it's all
the earth satellites and we're gonna
let's just start with like one question
that we might want to explore so suppose
there's a satellite in geosynchronous
orbit that we know has a dry mass of 500
kilograms what's it for who is running
it that's not an unreasonable question I
had someone from the air force tell me
that they have better data and they're
interested but you know what can we do
with the public data so let's flip over
so this strange loop so I need to give a
demo and that's so what does it mean to
ask that question so we're over here
we're in data science land we're using
ipython notebooks so we're gonna
simulate the country of operator can
people read that do I need to crank it
up higher bigger all right at some point
the plots like go to hell and for some
reason this thing has way too much title
bar all right all right so we'll try
that the so what we do here is just what
another simulate query so I've already
modeled the satellites data I've got a
I've grabbed a completely modeled
database of satellites with a population
in it and so I'm just gonna create a
temp table where I simulate satellites
that look like my satellite and the
limit there is a little different than
sea pool limit but it says basically
make me a thousand samples so I'm going
from a population to an actual table in
this case so then once I've created that
table of samples I can actually you know
do whatever I want with it I can run
selects against it or I can use my
little histogram plotting utility and I
pretty quickly fall out that you know
well this is almost certainly a
communication satellite it's probably in
the United States maybe because we
launched a lot of communication
satellites I don't know exactly why but
it could be from Russia China somebody
like that and so that's like a what-if
scenario like what if this happened
what else would I what else would be
true what else would have happened in
that in that scenario and we do that by
having a lot of samples and then being
able to do this sort of histogram type
analysis where you can come up with some
amount of probability so you could say
for example there's about a 25% chance
it's the USA communication satellite
so what if I wanted to do that without
BAE's DB let's just think that one
through a little bit so the the normal
way if you just hand this to somebody
and say well figure out what a 500
kilogram satellite in geosynchronous
orbit what's it for well the first thing
they'll do is be like well 500 is like a
number so an geosynchronous sounds
pretty canonical so it's I'm gonna look
at like widening my lens on the number
maybe like 400 to 600 so like my wife's
an astrophysicist and I actually don't
know how much satellites weigh or what
the variance is on that so it turns out
if you go 400 to 600 you find two Indian
satellites one for meteorology one for
communications so we could say it's a
50-50 chance that it's communications or
meteorology and it's probably from India
that kind of violates our intuition
because satellites are not generally
probably from India so I could be like
okay well maybe I was wrong 300 to 700
well now I get like what's more
communications it's only like 50 percent
communications and you know this is the
kind of data exploration that people are
often doing to try to come to a
conclusion on these what-if scenarios
and it's like hard and you know you end
up either needing an enormous amount of
domain expertise like I'm sure there are
people who know that satellite stuff
backwards and forwards and they don't
even need to run the thing they just say
like oh yeah 500 kilogram satellites are
always communications unless they're
spies something like that
so that's that's to simulate what else
can we do we talked about doing these
sort of infer so I've got the same
satellite population and I can start
doing things like data cleansing on it
or replacing missing data so as an
example I have there's a lot of
satellites where the type of orbit is
null and I can go ahead and infer
explicit against this and this is
actually a slightly different
formulation the language is more
complicated than just three key words so
with this formulation I'm actually
treating the confidence as data so I'm
predicting the type of orbit and I'm
actually also tracking the confidence in
that prediction and so that gets me back
a table where I have filled in a bunch
of types of orbits and I can see the
range of confidences so sometimes I'm
you know 70% confident sometimes I'm
much less you know 25% confidence
something like that so that's
interesting and can start to help me
understand like what does my data tell
me like what's what's really implied by
the
idea that I can predict some things with
confidence and some things without
confidence and so you can actually we
like these violin plots which tell us
this is looking at inferred confidence
versus the inferred orbit type so this
is like having chosen sun-synchronous
for an elliptical satellite what was my
range of confidences we're having chosen
and so what you can learn from that for
example is that it's easier for us to
predict low-earth orbit satellite orbit
types than it is to predict other orbit
types this is all really important
because remember that slide about you
know nobody trusts data analysis they
don't understand people aren't used to
getting confidence measures on the
answers they get from data scientists
like when you ask a data scientist is to
answer a question they just they give
you their best answer and how would you
get a confidence it's a little tricky
like you don't want anyway it's it's
tricky to imagine how you do this with
humans we have some theories what we
keep but what we're doing is saying this
is what it should look like when you can
do it and we'll show you a bit about how
we do it with our meta model what else
can we do we can also identify anomalies
so another way that you can run a
prediction against some data is to say
okay but I have data and given the data
that I have what is the how likely is
that is that data so in this case line
wrapping what I'm doing is saying an
estimate query so this is about that so
sometimes I infer missing stuff and
sometimes I make an estimate about the
probability of something I really do
have and so what I'm doing here is
saying given period minutes that I have
how likely is that how likely would I
would I have predicted that value and so
I can identify the unlikely periods and
that can be that can be interesting in
particular when I look at some of these
unlikely periods these are all
geosynchronous orbit satellites the most
unlikely periods are all for geo
satellites okay and the most likely
periods it turns out well geosynchronous
satellites actually have a very stable
period you know you just know what that
is and so these are all basically wrong
and one way or another these you know so
it's 24 hours is kind of the right
answer and so in this case it's about
this was a unit error somebody put it in
four hours
in in this case it was it was a decimal
points error because it was a decimal
points error
at any rate we're able to find things
with these you know 24 minutes 24 minute
periods we're able to realize that that
some of this that some of the data is
wrong and sort of dig into how confident
should I be in the data that I'm
starting with so let's see jump back to
slides
maybe there is
so we talked through the different kinds
of queries so that's that's like bql in
a nutshell it's the ability to explore
data by inferring missing values
simulating data estimating the
likelihood of data occurring and it
turns out that's actually most of the
rope you need or maybe all the Rope you
need to really understand and work with
a model two data set once you get into
the composability and what none of those
those capabilities but this would not be
interesting at all if we gave you the
ability to ask arbitrary questions of
data and we could not give you answers
so the other half of the puzzle is to
being able to model your data and give
you answers to all these wonderful
questions that you're able to ask and so
this machine assisted modeling because
people can ask infinite questions we
need a baseline answer and we need some
place for people to start as they work
on improving their modeling so what
would you do if you're trying to build a
general-purpose model for sort of
arbitrary data the the default
statistics 101 answer is correlation is
nice and these are just two dimensional
data sets XY which were you know they're
they're not there they're relatively
indicative of datasets that exist in the
real world but they were you know
relatively carefully chosen because what
we can show is that correlation
uniformly predicts that these are
there's no predictive power in this data
that the this the correlation is zero
between these data points because
they're they have this sort of evenness
or balance to them it turns out you know
as a human you'd like to you think you
can get some predictive power out of
that
and that's because you're better at
recognizing the shape of the data or
you're better at thinking of the data in
terms of clustering or different ways of
grouping the data subsets of the
information that come out and coming up
with a different model for different
subsets of the information and so we
have the system that goes beyond
relation to do that same logic to come
up with the mutually predictive subsets
of the information which allows us for
example on little systems like this to
you know be able to recover not
necessarily a perfect picture of the
shape but actually a pretty good
representation you know and something a
lot of what we do is yes you could do
better it's a little bit like the old
compiler versus assembly fights yes you
could do better if you're a brilliant
modeler or someone who understands the
domain perfectly and we'll get to that
in a minute
but it's kind of nice that the computer
can do stuff all by itself so what's
going on here what we've built is a
probabilistic meta model for inferring
model structure so we're gonna look at
your model we look at your samples your
data and try to identify looking at the
columns in the rows the right set of
views to have against this data and the
right set of categories to have against
this data so you think about this is
just kind of slicing your table so if
I'd that table of health care
information I might turn out that like
some of the demographic data is mutually
predictive some of the health
information is mutually predictive the
demographic data is not super predictive
of the health information or maybe it
sort of is so it's trying to figure out
like what's the right way to slice and
dice this data and when the data gets
large there's this combinatorial
explosion even to finally have a three
by three matrix
it's 205 possibilities it goes up pretty
fast and so that's why I'm here from the
probabilistic computing group because
the key insight to drive automated
modeling is the ability to really get
our arms around this problem and realize
that we don't need to solve it in any
way precisely or or you know with one
single answer but what we do need to do
is come up with a way for efficiently
getting to a good approximation in fact
what we're gonna do is efficiently get
to about a hundred good approximations
because computers are cheap and actually
we can get there pretty quickly so this
is an example of running the the
metamodel process which is basically we
initialize an ensemble of models and
then we try to adjust the cluster
noisiness so we look at each of these
little groups and say how good is the
mutual prediction within this group and
if it's or how would the mutual
prediction be better if I kicked this
element out and put it somewhere else
and then we just iterate that for long
enough you know Markov Monte Carlo
Markov
there'll be a little bit more on that
later today and what we eventually get
to is you know a pretty solid
decomposition of this so that was sorta
that was building a model for animals
based on their traits you know so
looking at animals and you probably
can't see it on the slide but the system
was pretty it was able to identify the
traits that relate to being a sea
creature and cluster all the sea
creatures together and this is a nice
little video because it it it's a human
could sit there and do the
categorization it's a small enough set
of data and come up with and have the
same sort of disputes about what the
exact right categorization is and then
eventually end up with something that
looks not dramatically dissimilar from
from what we get and what we do then is
to do that about a hundred times or
enough times so that we have an ensemble
of models that we can use and we can
model the data repeatedly and that's one
of the ways that we develop this notion
of confidence which is am i getting the
same answer from all the models so what
does an automatic model tell you it can
tell you this sort of pairwise
dependence probability and this is
actually a really interesting one
because it sort of tells you the
predictive power of your data this is a
heat map that we like people like
looking at what we've done is to
identify a dark square is a look it's
the same columns on the XY axis on the x
and y axis and a dark square indicates
that two columns are predictive of one
another and the cluster in the top left
corner in this instance is shows you
that basically countries tend to by
satellites from the same contractors
there's a consistency you can predict
what contract or satellite comes from if
you know what country it's from or if
you know what contractors building it
etc and then in the the rest of the
picture you actually have you see
clusters around the physical
characteristics of the satellite so
we're trying to what we're doing is
recovering is recovering the orbital
mechanics of this the details of how
that could work in fact let me flip over
the notebook and what we can see is that
you know so there was that graph that I
showed you where we'd recovered normal
mechanics if we look at just a baseline
correlation so it's not just my
contrived data sets that fail at
correlation if I run correlation on the
satellites with orbital it
get nothing for a little mechanic's all
we get is that the countries are
correlated with the owners which is not
unreasonable but we end up missing out
on all those details of orbital stuff of
you know masses things like that we do I
think find out yeah we do know that like
launch mast dry mass and power are
correlated that's the other thing that
correlation can pick up but as for the
details of how the orbits work it's it's
somewhat hopeless and a data scientist
will tell you well you just need to
pre-process your data hard enough and
you'll eventually get there but that's
the goal is to say what can we do
automatically with you know relatively
lightweight with with minimal
pre-processing so how can you refine the
model what can you do to make the model
better well one thing you can do is tell
us things we shouldn't bother
considering so a lot of times we get
data sets that have where two columns
are like a strict function of one
another
height weight and height weight ratio
and you're like the system ends up you
know chewing up a certain amount of CPU
and assigning columns in different
places because it's in the parts
figuring out that height weight and
height rate ratio have like a nice
structured correlation so you just tell
us ahead of time that that's true or if
you tell us ahead of time that you know
I know my data is skewed in some way but
actually these two things are
uncorrelated it's just an artifact of
how I got my data so you can give us
assertions about dependence and
independence and this is the language
that we're looking at expanding like
what can people say here but you could
also realize that you know if you're
doing satellites there's like this guy
who spent some time figuring out how
satellites worked and so you can
actually take Kepler's laws and say okay
I actually have a physical model for how
this part of the data is supposed to
work and I can actually look at
extending the metamodel composing
together multiple models I'm combining
the default model on the bottom with a
foreign model of Kepler's laws I've also
tagged in a random forest model which is
just sort of an off-the-shelf model from
statistics or machine learning I guess
would be people to be more accurate and
so by doing that I can actually get to
something that is much more predictive
that it does a better job predicting all
those orbital mechanics pop parameters
so if this is something I actually care
about it makes sense to take the time to
implement Kepler's laws and they're over
here in this tab and so then I end up
with a
a model population where the model is
actually derived from this sort of
physical reality this stuff that I know
about physics and so what can I do with
that I can well I can basically do my
standard simulation trick so I'm going
to simulate Apogee and perigee from the
satellite so the nice thing about this
simulation is I'm going to be simulating
the orbital mechanics parameters from
using Kepler's laws but the inputs the
Kepler's laws are going to be generated
by the default model so I'm combining
multiple modeling technologies together
here and so in order to do that or when
I do that I get this plot that's it this
takes a minute to digest I'm getting
used to the process of like looking at a
graph slowly I spent too long in
business where you look at every graph
and expect something to go up into the
right so looking at this a little bit
more slowly the purple line down the
center is basically you know the
possible domain of answers to Kepler's
laws like that's what Kepler's law says
possible Apogee and perigee are given
that period you you can't be outside of
that other than noises noise in your
observation of course there's always
noise in your observation the blue dots
which are clustered along that line
unsurprisingly are the blue dots are the
actual observed satellites the red dots
are where we simulated things and so you
can kind of have two reactions to this
you can say like wow your red dots are
like all over the place or I could say
like yeah but like my red dots are like
not that badly all over the place that
they're kind of on the line and that's
kind of nice and in fact you know
notably the computer does not know that
these are satellites or and it knows
nothing about Newtonian mechanics or any
of that stuff and we got you like
partway there but yeah I mean if you're
unsatisfied with the default model for a
little mechanics that's great you should
not use the default model for orbital
mechanics you should plug in the green
dots which are an orbital model
simulation when we've done with the
green dots it's a little bit more
sophisticated than just implementing
Kepler's laws we've actually created a
model that's trained to identify the
noise that's likely that comes from the
data set so actually train the orbital
mechanics model because we want it to
represent the data were actually going
to see not the idealized physical world
and so that's why the green dot sort of
move off the line a bit but in theory
and I think
the green dots move off the line about
the same amount that the blue dots do
and everything ends up copacetic there's
different ways we can look at that we
can say for each dimension you know how
much error are we getting in the red and
this is always fun so this is why one of
the things we like to do is model a
dataset and then work with a domain
expert to understand like but what's the
right answer and then start to
understand where do we deviate from that
or what's what's to be learned from that
process yeah and this is a different way
of looking at that the two purple lines
are different eccentricities of the
orbit and you also can see here that the
red dots do a decent job filling in
between the purple lines there's
actually a surprising there are
surprisingly eccentric actual satellites
in the database we ran out of domain
expert time before we actually get to
the bottom of that and we also have a
big cluster down here which is we're
obviously also a lot of the the actual
satellites are so that was the story
about how you can refine the model so we
talked through so we talked through
Bayes DB which is you get this bql thing
which is allows you to make utterances
about inference about inference
reasoning against data sets or against
pup I'm not supposed to say data sets
inference freezing against populations
which is a population is a model as a
modeled it's modeled data so you view
inference against populations and then
you have this meta modeling languages
how you build these populations how you
get the model sorted out how you train
things up how you integrate third party
systems and between those two things you
know we have a system that makes makes
it possible to query the probable
implications of your data and we think
makes this kind of inference based
reasoning or empirical inference much
more accessible both from people who
want to just understand what question
was asked and also people who want to
get their hands dirty doing more
modeling so we're here to talk about
future programming we're pretty clear
other were future what are we doing in
terms of programming so there's some
aspects of programming which are just
like the query language this and
actually there's some aspects to
programming which is like the system's
infrastructure getting this stuff right
so Bayes DB we're is proudly open source
apache license as
or 22nd you can pip install it it's a
combination of Python and C++ code you
will need boost and all that stuff you
can read the documentation but you know
you can pip install it and run Bayes DB
demo and you will actually see what I
showed you today - the orbital mechanics
that's on a branch in the repository
machine assisted modeling is something
we're actually still holding back on so
where we are right now is we've we've
released it you can do bql you can
download model populations and you can
interact with them we're still we're
running an alpha process for people who
want to actually model their data I'll
talk about that in a moment and we're
looking at building out that as a as a
service so that we can actually help
people model their data without having
eight on the phone with them but also
still not leave people sort of
unanchored trying to model their data in
isolation because we are still doing a
lot of work around assessing quality and
safety of these models and understanding
when do we do a good job when do we do a
bad job what do those words even mean
and in particular we're seeking
compelling datasets for collaboration
and ideally publication so if you have
data that's interesting and you're a
domain expert in that data and
especially if that data is something
that can be public and become public we
would love to talk but so future
programming so one thing about
programming we started out with a
command-line shell for this thing and
then as we talk to people who are
actually domain experts actually doing
data science with real data and
astrophysics and healthcare and things
like that they were like not fans of the
terminal you know read line command line
shell and they said everybody uses
notebooks you should use notebooks okay
so we recast the thing over the last
month as a notebook and works great in
notebooks so you can do plotting and all
that and Python open tracks are kind of
nice they're good for giving demos but
it's still like not the best interactive
environment so one question for this
audience or for people who are thinking
about future programming is like what's
the interactive environments supposed to
be like for this and there's a bunch of
questions there are around data
visualization around query languages
around usability you know when should
people be able to ask for you know the
machine to spend more time doing
inference on a particular subset of the
data or in a particular query how does
it make sense even ask that question you
know should we immediately give people
bad answers before the type machine has
had enough time to Tanel
the data or should we wait until we've
reached some baseline quality before we
give people answers there's a whole
wealth of things around usability and
how to interact with this system out
there and then yeah as I mentioned we're
running this alpha if you go to the
website scroll to the bottom you can
apply to be alpha and you can bring your
own data to be modeled we'd like to be
working with people we are working with
people on you know healthcare of
bioinformatics Pharma astrophysics and
are in a range of other things but I'm
talking to people at global warming and
climate data talking to people about
other datasets because you know it turns
out an enormous fraction of Natural
Science is now being more and more data
driven and the people who are doing that
science don't necessarily have the best
tools and so there's opportunities for
us in the computer science or
programming community to work on giving
them better tools so I could take
questions I think if that's what we do
yes
and this is okay yeah absolutely it was
great I love what you're doing why'd you
use sequel because nobody's learned data
log in a hundred years the because so
this is Great Depression like I fought
oh oh sorry to repeat the question the
question was why did you use sequel
syntax or possibly just I object to
sequel syntax so let me answer why you
didn't use sequel syntax that's a better
question it's like why didn't you do
something else
think about or why don't you change now
because we did just change from like a
command-line shell that fights on
notebook so why don't you change now so
the questions like what should we change
to you know the sequel is kind of a
lingua franca in this space like
everybody knows it even if they don't
like it
and so that's it's that the sort of
pseudo English phrasing is helpful to
certain kinds of accessibility I'm happy
to hear that there's a different
language structure that's that gets you
better accessibility but it's something
that people do feel like they can
understand it's something that people
were trying to get to use the data feel
like they understand and you know I
spent a while fighting about this at
stream base so we you know stream base
we had a visual environment for building
queries people really wanted a query
language they almost universally wanted
it to be SQL so that was like another
you know shove in the direction of SQL
there is a question about whether we're
trying to be remotely sequel 89
compliant or anything like that it is
nice that as you're in the middle of
modeling your populations you can go
back and forth between inference based
modeling and just regular sequel syntax
the histograms and the group buys and
aggregations combining data things like
that so there's there's a lot of
benefits to it and you know it wasn't
the only serious suggestion that we
considered was something in the link
type space which is I think only a
difference of degree from sequel but I'm
happy to hear things in fact I guess
I'll ask you again and you can tell me
the answer
yes do a follow-up and all of them
eventually build secret yes yes yep
right that is a lovely incite so the
statement was you know we have a golden
opportunity to make people learn
something new or do at least experiment
with something new because we're giving
them a whole bunch of new superpowers
and they'll they're willing to learn
terrible languages to get them they're
currently using sass so they have no
taste so we might as well try to give
them something of interest you are
absolutely correct and they're one of
the major reasons I i justified coming
to this conference was because we are a
small research group that is able to
focus on certain things that we are very
good at the process of exploring the
programming language design space around
this it may not be one of those things
one of the reasons to open-source it is
to understand is to make it something
that other people can do research on
that other people can base things on and
so if there are people who do want to
have a different query formalism that
they like better who or want to suggest
one and in particular if they want to
like dig in and build one on top you
know pull requests appreciated it's on
github anything else anybody else yes
you know a few hundred but it's actually
it's a so I've been told actually let me
let me repeat the question
what's get what how many dimensions does
your model scale up to and that there's
like two ways to answer that the the
sort of the intellectual answer is
that's actually the wrong way to think
about the size of your data and in
particular a lot of the question becomes
what what do you know about the data how
much can you tell us ahead of time like
if you already understand your data in a
relatively sophisticated way then the
automatic modeling can just you know
fill in the constants for you and get it
done if you're coming in with data that
you know nothing about then there are
lots of places where you can find
yourself outside the the design envelope
for the automatic modeling and you know
hundreds of columns and hundreds of
columns is kind of the way you should be
thinking about it if you have something
with 30,000 columns which one of the
people I'm talking to does you should
ask yourself if you really have time
series data or what exactly you have but
we're also happy to we are very
interested in datasets that are outside
those parameters because from a research
perspective the most interesting and
stuff we can't model that we should be
able to other questions yes
sure yeah it depends it depends a bit on
the query like you know as you probably
all noticed that I heard some of you
noticed that I didn't actually run them
when I was going here so if I go let's
see if I can get this going
you toolbar I mean relatively quickly
the goal is for they they should be
delivering interactive performance some
queries do not and one of the things
that we're actually working with right
now is demo itis one of things were
actually working with right now is
understanding how do we signal to people
that the query they just asked for is
computationally expensive so like
simulating a lot of satellites turns out
some of the simulations against Kepler's
laws are very expensive because our
implication of implementation of
Kepler's laws only solves them in one
way and
we need like a closed-form solution the
other way and we didn't write one so
sometimes it's like what your model is
slow in one way and not the other or
something along those lines but for
example let's see so run the simulation
of creating the table that actually that
just ran and completed so whatever 15
seconds actually let me make that real a
few I give up
oh oh oh right speaking of things we
don't like about sequel yeah okay so so
we can we can do a lot of simulations
you know we can do very quickly some of
the inferences we can do quickly this
pairwise probability this pairwise
predictive probability is still scales
as like basically N squared there's an
opportunity to improve the performance
of that through some algorithmic
optimization that we haven't done so it
basically asks it Basques it runs a
query for every cell of the heatmap so
that takes a while like actually I can
how long does that one take we'll see if
that finishes before I'm done talking
other questions yes
yes
yes okay
that's that is a very good question and
if there are no more questions class is
dismissed
you know that's actually so the answer
is the the the a generative predict I'm
sorry oh I'm sorry
so that the question was what is the
interface that allows those models to be
composed or how do we actually how do we
how do we drive composition from those
models and I'm gonna go slightly off the
reservation and see if I don't get
myself in trouble no wait
right I lost it
where is it I told myself I should have
this opening a I should I go like that
then I will see all right so Kepler's
laws we initialize a model basically the
two functions you need to implement in
the current code base and we're actually
adjusting this right now is simulate and
log PDF so you just the model just need
to be able to simulate new data points
given partial records are given
conditions I should say and it needs to
be able to give the probability
distribution function for a given a
value how likely was was it to have seen
this value and that is I think enough
rope we think enough rope there's a math
paper that says it's enough rope and
there's another speaker in a minute
who's who wrote the math paper so I will
appeal to Authority and be done so
that's so that was the answer to the
question of how do we how do we make
these things composable we have a pretty
thin interface that we think is adequate
they're actually then from a database
perspective opportunities to violet
abstractions and make things go faster
so one of the reasons that that Kepler's
is slow is because it has to chew
through that interface like a lot of
times and you could probably come up
with a way to make that more efficient
anyway other questions okay great
oh you have a break in between okay
[Applause]